Well, many people are avoiding traveling right now,...
...but if you still need to get on a plane for some reason,...
...some seats are more likely to keep you from getting sick.
The enclosed space, recirculated air and the number of people...
...make planes prime breeding grounds for bacteria.
The tray table was by far the most contaminated surface tested.
It was followed by the overhead air vent, the lavatory flush button...
...and the seatbelt buckle.
So what could travelers do to help fend off illness above cruising altitude?
Well, carry antibacterial wipes and hand sanitizers,...
...wipe down that tray table, seatbelt buckles, armrest and seat back pockets...
...when you sit down.
Hydrate and choose a window seat.
In fact, people who sit by the window have the smallest risk of infection...
...because they have the least contact with others.